am i enough
just the way i am
or do i constantly need
new equipment
new material new goods in my life new
experiences to feel full
in some form
so that's something that really changed
here
[Music]
melania left her nine to six office job
in berlin and moved to the countryside
in brandenburg to set up a communal
living space together with her partner
that is the kind of community we want to
build
small local
deeper connections
also the possibility to heal within the
group
in a group process connected to nature
and living in a more sustainable and
slow way
as the global economy emerges from the
pandemic millions of people around the
world are rethinking their work-life
balance
i bought a lot of useless things i
realized now i mean i love clothes and i
love
nice things and shoes
but here i don't need any of those
things it's a real freedom it feels like
i can just kind of like
let all these things go and come out of
my shell
in china tech and finance workers have
rallied against a grueling work schedule
known as 996
working 9 am to 9 pm 6 days a week
some young people in china are
frustrated by the high stress and slow
growth in their career and are choosing
to adopt a
foreign
quit their jobs in beijing and moved to
a mountain village in zhang jiaji
they vlog their lives while building
facilities in their rural house
[Music]
but
[Music]
is living in shenzhen while studying a
master's degree online
the society needs more definition about
success all the people around you are
doing so well or you're all competing
for the same job or for the same kind of
success
so you kind of like fear you are gonna
left out so some people just give up and
then tanking
lying flat could be a sign of economic
stagnation
in some parts of china there are regions
where growth slowed to two percent
pre-pandemic
even where incomes are still growing it
doesn't always feel that way house
prices in the largest cities have risen
much faster than incomes making cities
like shenzhen among the world's least
across the european union two million
fewer people are in work than before the
coronavirus struck